seamlessly look there
those workforces of the air
with the Union flag flying along the
rear
wrote a tail
it's one o'clock you're watching Sky
News as his majesty the king with the
queen and other members of the royal
family watch the flight pass from the
balcony of Buckingham Palace
wonderfully from the second world war
the Lancaster bomber
with one Spitfire and two hurricanes
[Music]
they battle a Britain flight maintaining
that
and they pull back to see in the skies
who comes next that wonderful sight
flying overhead
[Music]
foreign
s who have the Hercules who've been
flying all over the United Kingdom in a
completion of their duty to the Royal
Air Force
those of you who saw them flying across
different parts of the Kingdom will
remember their Roar I've certainly flown
in many during my time in the armed
forces and we will miss them as they
also give their salute to the king
and we'll not see them again
they were due to fly over
during the coronation and even though
they have officially gone out of service
they were allowed to take part in this
occasion
the significance that they represent
[Music]
master
massive aircraft
does the heavy lift on operations
known as the C-17 Globe master
which comes from RAF Bryce Norton a lot
of the family getting that great Raw
they say that
the RAF Atlas
and
before it the RAF Poseidon
[Music]
we've seen The Voyage of the atlas of
Poseidon and typhoons keeping
be Poseidon safe
that will come the lightnings
of course all these aircraft go at
different speeds
and have to be factored into the fly
past routine very carefully
[Music]
and as with all good tactical flying
it's quite difficult to find for our
helicopter pilot
you see the Princess Royal looking
around the side of the
Victoria Memorial to try and see where
the
lightning are coming from
[Music]
six Lightnings
f-35bs a great rule
thank you
the king's grandchildren rather enjoying
that I think
then we've got 18 typhoons coming the
fgr4s
in the shape of CR carolus Rex
Charles King
foreign
[Applause]
shouldn't underestimate the effort and
practice and rehearsal that members of
the Armed Forces have put into this
celebration of the nation in the person
of the Kings
official birthday
lastly
nine Hawks from the Royal Air Force
aerobatics team known as the red arrows
in red white and blue
and with an Envoy for CC1 in the middle
[Music]
oh
Buckingham Palace with the red white and
blue as the Red Arrows curl to the right
to avoid the Heathrow flight path and
for the king
end of
his first birthday parade is sovereign
where he took the salute from first
battalion
the Welsh guards
[Applause]